okay thank you so again thank you for
the to the organizers for the invitation
to come speaker today it's been really
thought-provoking meetings thus far and
the that session last night also threw
me into an existential crisis about what
I'm supposed to be doing with my life in
science and questions I should be
answering let's see if I address any of
those today so yeah well exactly i see i
have new things now that keep me up and
I so I'm going to talk today about some
of our work you know this is a problem
that I think many of us are confronted
with which is the specificity of
homologs and related proteins how does
this jonatha this just worked
that's the bit one sec let me unplug and
plug it back in it's not working now oh
did it go okay all right so evolution
has provided us with these large
families of homologs and particularly
you care about genomes were left with
this issue of how do we understand
specificity in the light of large
families of very often similar
transcription factors and if you ever
needed a picture to put your mind to
they represented the problem with
homologs I think it's this one and they
chose to include on the front of this
book I have no idea what the
conversation was like when they decided
on that picture for that book so this
issue of homologs and and similar
binding specificity really raises too I
think kind of interrelated issues and
I'm going to talk about both of those
today we've had projects in both and the
first is if things are evolving by
duplication and neyo functionalization
or changes how does that lead to the
evolution new binding specificities in
transcription factors okay we know that
gene regulatory networks are a primary
mechanism by which evolution and that
adaptation occurs and so we've thought a
lot about the sis side of it but the
trans side of evolution hasn't been
studied as much and so that's one thing
we can look at by comparing hollow logs
the other is just so this is sort of
depicted here by this diagram you'd
imagine we have a transcription factor
and it has some target genes and in time
you know maybe it evolved to have very
new target genes and you can imagine
with duplication and real neo
functionalization this would occur and
this would allow us to get new
regulatory networks alternatively
perhaps it happens like this where
because of the constraints and
structural biology maybe you have an
overlapping set of target genes you get
some new ones you have to lose some and
so the question of how transcription
factors evolve is still a really open
question and I think you can the same
diagram sort of illustrates the problem
we have with homologs in a cell so
transcription factors that are similar
expressed in the same time in a Cell we
have this problem are and end often I
think many of us are confronted with
this problems that we you know in terms
of Chipper gene expression we see that
they have overlapping but not the same
set of target genes and so how much of
its real where is the specificity coming
from and the second part of my talk will
address this we have a set of factors we
really want to know where are they
getting their uniqueness from okay so
these are the two questions we're going
to talk about and so in terms of the
data i think what i'm going to talk
about today and some of the ideas i
think are really being pushed by lots of
these eight high-throughput techniques
so there's many many technologies is
from a recent review we had
methodologies or modalities that allow
many many protein DNA binding
measurements and the question is what do
we do with that information and some of
us in armond's talked about that raluca
talked about i think others will talk
about that today and I think these large
data sets
good I'm just gonna oh that's really
delayed isn't it maybe I gotta shake it
I'm just you know I'm just gonna use the
i'll use the the button I don't know
gonna work then
okay now let me talk about this yeah
it's fine so so so i think that the
issues that come from these i want to
talk about the insights you can get from
these rich data sets they're very rich
and I think sometimes the simple models
we derive actually mask some complexity
think is really interesting all right so
and that's going to relate to these
issues with simple models and then and
then the last part of the talk want to
talk about how we should design these
experiments so that I can really learn
the best the models from from the data
I'm going to talk about to start state
two short stories that hopefully will
keep your attention for ten minutes and
ten minutes so the first is evolution of
zinc fingers so this idea of how we can
use these rich data sets to understand
evolution of transcription factors and
this is a paper that came out a couple
years ago this is a work with me and
started to Martha Bullock's lab where I
was a postdoc and finished in my lab now
it'd be you and the last one is on
regulation of pathogen sensing and this
is very unpublished data because we just
got the data last week so you're going
to see the very rough and ready look at
the data and some of the problems were
confronted with okay so evolution thank
you this may work okay hi when I go so
the zinc fingers this is a huge family
massive expansions of zinc fingers have
occurred throughout many many organisms
and one of the reasons we know about
them is gonna have an interesting
modular binding unfold this what i mean
by that is the individual fingers tend
to recognize sets of so here's the amino
acids sets of sort of roughly triplets
okay and this has allowed us to use them
to set up companies to design zinc
fingers and obviously this is being
crispers pushing this into a new
direction now so maybe we won't use this
as much but it's still a big business
but it's also about evolution to use the
same principles which is duplication and
modularization and change of these
modular reader heads to get new
specificities okay and what was
interesting about this family for me is
that we kind of understood the
principles so I kind of knew which amino
acids we're supposed to recognize which
bases okay so I thought okay good this
is a good one to look at let me see if I
can understand how they're evolving
so we started in yeast yeast has there's
really cool family of many many factors
for its there's only two so it's a
simple zinc finger model you see it's
two reader heads and because of genome
duplications we have these families and
so I organize these are all the members
I organize them by their canonical
recognition residues so the residues
that I know mediate specificity I said
well let's put them into groups that
should by all by what we understand
buying the same DNA okay and then the
ones here so there's two proteins here
and I put the line here to demarcate
those that resulted from a relatively
not that recent genome whole genome
duplication in yeast and so they're very
similar paralogs so then the question I
have and I 0 zoomed in on one of these
families there's five proteins here that
should bind the same DNA did these bind
the same deal today by different DNA
sets the same DNA sites and how do they
deviate from the canonical model so we
had these really rich data sets some of
this was from Martha's lab someone's
from tim hughes lab and of a yeast
compendium paper and they they measure
the binding specificity using a
universal PBM so this is protein binding
microarray they have all possible eight
murders encoded in overlapping fashion
and they can do very comprehensive
measurements to small cameras and this
was good because these factors actually
bind small camera so this is a really
nice data set for these facts
now when you take this really rich data
set instead of looking at logos I said
let me look at the whole rich data set
so if i compare the binding of two
proteins I can look at it visually like
this so every one of these dots is a
neighbor and the neighbor is assigned to
fluorescence value and so we can plot
those okay so this is the whole
landscape so up here yes robusto the
manor right so Joe you know which were
doesn't buy doesn't just assign yeah
yeah you look at all amer's you look at
the median fluorescence intensity
associated with each a demur they each
ate mer comes in many many different
sequence context and so it's a median
intensity for all the probes on which
that eight more occurred yeah so this is
a technology to route 10 years and
they've been yeah sure sure sure so
these instances are all we do the same
least you know different okay let me go
back yeah given her so these are all
yeast from saccharomyces cerevisiae and
and these are into five individual genes
and I've organized them together because
they all have the same canonical amino
acid recognition positions the DNA on
the array is completely synthetic yeah
we're good is there another question
yeah yeah so is it a good reason why why
you don't just block the throat in 10
cities against each other while you go
to these medium today sure sure sure
skizz the probe intensity the probes are
32 base pairs long with a primer and
they're a composite probe of many
overlapping Amer's so I could do that
absolutely but then what i'm looking at
i would have to deacon and say rights so
tell you directly how different the
measurement says the binding of these
two guys are to the probes it would
certainly say I could definitely look at
the distribution of the probes and then
it went say I did that and I said oh
look there's something over here that's
bound strongly by this factor but poorly
by this factor that I would have these
probes 32 base pairs long and I wouldn't
know what in it was important so I'd
have to do some deconvolution anyways so
I could do both that clear because it's
many many potential binding sites
that's totally clear it's just that
y'all know how much of this sort of
mismatch yo you are from these ain't no
games that you're playing rather than
yeah I can show you because we actually
measure kds for individual aimers and it
agrees well as the fluorescence yeah we
do MSS to validate the the binding
energy gym and then action the last part
of the talk i'll show you for these new
factors we do exactly what you want we
made binding sites in constant flank
regions measure the intensities to those
where we've changed the binding sites
thing and did the distribution so we
play the game with whatever data sets we
have this was available for us okay so
basically I'm going to talk about today
is there's richness in this data that I
think it's not captured by the simple
pwm model okay so I have these five
factors I know this little grainy this
is from the huge lab paper this is just
the logos that I originally saw when I
came to this I knew something about sig
figs and I thought those seem kind of
similar but are those differences that I
seen the logo actually real in other
words is there more there than meets the
eye so we took the eight MERS we simply
correlated them and said do they group
into specificity clusters and sure
enough we had we did some measurements
are on our own so calm too is actually
this one msn to ms and for these clothes
paralogs are here and this is it and
then these members had multiple
measurements from papers from martha
from Tim and ourselves and it was clear
they had three different specificity
groups that didn't quite to me track
with the motifs ok so maybe motifs
weren't learned right but we looked a
little more and so if we scatter these
eight MERS like I just showed you you
can start saying well let's look at
these specific spots that are specific
to one of the factors and not the other
so we came up with an algorithm to
determine a p-value for difference and
so I'm just going to tell you that for
the purposes of this top these yellow
ones are calm to specific in other words
they're much more preferred by this
factor than this factor these purple
ones are preferred by this factor and
then we have some common sites and so I
said well let's look at the binding
sites and say what's different between
these
and we see this actually for throughout
the family so here's comparisons with
comp 2 and here's with us v1 okay and
when you look at them you see that
there's clear differences in other words
the combat probes look like the
consensus we expected the msn to
preferred ones here in purple have a
really distinct GC selection here and
then these yellow ones have a different
biology for repeats yeah it's almost a
perfect diagonal we have that I don't
have it here but I have in my computer
we could I could show it to them yeah
yeah they're very tight in fact what i
have is ms into msn for which is the
close paralog that looks like a tight
diagonal yeah yeah generate these bottom
mother's I mean you probably had some
items which were not exactly aligned
yeah this was actually just from the
Amos register align and look at the
frequencies is very rough and ready to
get a sense for the specificity
difference yeah and so to get your point
one of the things I want to know is
whether these differences were real and
so we measured the of this eight more we
measured the binding KD by by emsa and
saw this difference in in fluorescence
between these is about tenfold KD and
this is about a tenfold KD so we knew
these differences we were seeing or at
least real in an equilibrium ining sense
okay is that clear okay so these are
real we can pick them out and the
question is how do they get here so this
is what confused me there was the
evolution these things for all intents
purposes should be binding the same DNA
sequence that's the mom we know for zinc
fingers but they don't so why not so the
first thing I said was well let me look
at the sequence alignment across
different yeast species and I'm glossing
over some data here we actually clone
these from many many different species
and we did the experiments and they were
all the same so they hadn't diverged for
about 200 million years so within these
groups the specificity was conserved and
so we found that in one of them there is
this conserved piece of protein outside
of the canonical zinc fingers so I
hadn't been discussed much that
approaching outside the stinkers
wouldn't mediate specificity to me this
is the take home slide for the richness
of the data and this
I don't have an an algorithm that
demonstrated identify why I what am I
trying to say what am I trying to say
this was just on a hot picture to me
that demonstrated something interesting
about the data so we took these zinc
fingers we mutated this little peptide
so its basic here we mutated it to some
acidic amino acids and what you saw is
those specific amino acids for come to
vanished and now we have a much more
correlated specificity here importantly
the affinity to these consensus spots
didn't really change in other words
there was a modularity zinc finger
binding where you could mutate
selectivity to just some sites so
there's a part of the protein that said
oh you can you can expand your
specificity to now recognize new site so
we can imagine in terms of evolution
going this way we we gained some basic
tale that now allows us to select a new
set of sites but we can still recognize
the old sites all right so we don't have
to throw the baby out with the bathwater
we can just gained new specificities
what do you mean by the other way around
if we oh that's a good point so if we
took msn to and added that basic tail
doesn't work I don't gain that
specificity so it must mean that there's
additional amino acids that allow it to
be permissive for that and I tried and I
couldn't figure out what they were so
there's still hidden mysteries even
within this yes I can break it I can't
make it and the other one I'll show you
I'm going to gloss some details but we
made it for another one and it was
complicated messy but we were able to do
it okay so and again this is just the
equilibrium binding I'm going to skip
over that interest of time so here is
our model that you had a zinc-finger
binding mill which could recognize the
common sites for this family and at
least one of the members gained a new
peptide along with some other magic
amino acids that I don't yet understand
that allowed to bind new sites and in
terms of Remos interest where
everything's in it can be thought of in
terms of a minor groove interaction we
actually think that that's what's going
on this rgr peptide is one that Remo had
identified as being often used by
protein factors to recognize 80 rich
miner grooves and that's exactly what we
see when you have that basic region you
select for you increase your affinity
for 80 flanking sequences so there was
this other family member eilen good I'm
going to just gloss over the details and
tell you here's our other model so this
is all published now so in fact what it
was those two completely different
mechanisms were playing one of them had
nothing to do with the tails we lop the
tails off and it was almost a complete
line and then again I can show you how
tight those fits our and the other one
is a bunch of amino acids that allowed
the fingers we think to change
orientation okay now in terms of binding
specificity and why I raised this for
this meeting is this really demonstrated
that two things were going on one in
terms of evolution you could get modular
gain of specificity okay you can change
amino acids by new sites in terms of the
richness of the data we would miss this
and if we if I hadn't sort of looked at
the data set and said well what are
these off diagonal points may mutations
looked at
the movement of the rich data said I
think I would have missed this and so to
me this is just a demonstration why
we've been spending a lot of time
looking at these kind of scatter plots
and rich data sets to understand
specifies minutes okay so here's very
new data so this is a project now that's
under that we're doing in the lab and
this the project is to understand the
regulation of pathogen sensing so an
important part of the inflammatory
process is the recognition of pathogens
and turning on inflammatory genes and so
we have whole sets of these sensor
molecules the toll-like receptors get a
lot of attention as early pathogen
sensing molecules and there are other
classes to that sentence things in the
cytosol and what as we went for we've
been studying this certain regulators of
this process and we came across this
group of proteins so though the
interferon regulatory factors that are
very homologous and they regulate sort
of disjoint sets of these in other words
they're differentially regulated by
these toll-like receptor by these
pathogens sensing a receptors and so the
question is how does their regulation
their target genes affect the subsequent
inflammatory response and how does it
Taylor and so what was puzzling is that
these things have been proposed to bind
the same sequence okay so they're dimers
they bind the consensus interferon
sensitive response element so the
question is wearing does their
specificity occur if they bind the same
sequences
we knew that they do different things in
vivo one of the most notable things is
that certain members are upregulated
strongly in certain autoimmune diseases
so they clearly must regulate slightly
different sets of target genes one
question is why I are five is so
commonly associated with it as opposed
to some of the other ones they bind the
same sequence and this is kind of a busy
slide but I'm just going to go over very
quickly what we know is that if you
overexpress these dimers and activated
forms they regulate different sets of
interferon alphas okay so we know that
even under conditions that are
comparable overexpression in the same
cell type they can turn on different
genes so the details are unimportant
just the fact that there is specificity
differences so this is from the grant we
proposed so there's you know multiple
possibilities for where they get their
specificity differences the simplest one
is perhaps they actually don't bind the
same sequence perhaps they have
different binding specificities and the
others is perhaps they interact with
cofactors and so we're studying all
three of you step so I'm just going to
talk about early data addressing this so
we had a logo available this is from
these beautiful companions from the dome
at all paper and ESCO I think we'll talk
about some of the motif finding for some
of these things later and so we have
these wonderful data sets but one of the
things that when I first look through
the data I thought again just like I had
with the previous papers how much do I
believe the little differences and this
is no there's a different motivation
when you really want to extend one
problem well you really want the details
you really want to understand I want to
understand if every single one I want
that the model that Leonid wants I want
that god-given Delta G model because I
want to make very precise predictions
and so when I look these I thought well
this is interesting but there's some
issues that I wonder about here's the
sort of consensus model the IRC with to
direct repeat kind of elements and then
you know for the earth three model I see
that there's a little bit upstream is
that really specific to earth three or
is that something the motif finding I
don't know her five had this dimeric
model as well as a monomer model is that
specific to earth i can earth five bines
imanam and the others don't
from the motifs I don't know that and so
and again earth seven and then there's
even the differences within these things
these small differences there's a see
here but nothing here are these real do
I believe these differences I mean
that's where I was at so we said well
you know I don't want to do a thousand I
want to do three so I'm going to do
three in excruciating detail and asked
whether I can get a better model or or
more detailed model and how will that
help my predictions so it turns out the
earth dimers are actually require
phosphorylation to form the dimeric
forms and the experiments hadn't been
done previously and I'm sort of it's
interesting that the John motifs are as
good as they are quite frankly because I
think they over expressed them as in in
HEK cells so and they weren't activated
so I don't surprised they got that is
that the motifs as close as they did so
that may be an issue with overexpression
cells and doing the selling anyhow so we
decided to bite the bullet we made these
fossil maddox so we made we my student
made a lot of mutations and so these
form dimers they've been showing
themselves to become to be consistently
actin so we did our binding assays with
these activated dimeric forums and hope
that we could you know really look at
the right species so the question is
here's the conceptual question I want to
ask what what probes if I can if I can
design probes to look at this what
should I put in there so we've seen
people talk today about the genome
context PBMs that Luke and Remo have
looked at where you can look at the
flanks and the important aspects of DNA
bend ability should I just take if I
really want to understand snip should I
just be taking sites and making snip you
tations and measuring the affinity in
other words what's the best approach
just take many much a lot of data and
learn a model or to actually take very
specific sequences and mutate them and
ask what the changes are so we did both
we decided to do both in the context of
this simple set of family so we've
included several thousand of these
genome context pbms drive from chip seek
data so the Gypsy did is of questionable
quality but we took many of these sites
we also have what I'm going to call
these snip type probes so we took many
many sites I think 50 sites we
exhaustively mutated every base position
and just said all right you know if I
really want understand snips I want to
make a good model let me just do that
and see how well it agrees with Marlo
they learn another way so you have many
of these and we can imagine that
eventually we're going to transform this
fluorescence into some sort of an energy
type model and the question I want to
know is how much data we need to do this
how reliable is and how well does it fit
models learned another way because we
care so much about the family too we
said well you know like I showed you
before the motif suggested there were
differences in different parts of the
binding site and so one can either just
learn models and say okay look there are
differences there or you can go test it
directly so we decided to test it
directly so sequence this is the
canonical sequence and then there's some
suggestion that there was some important
I mean I base positions five prime to
that so we said well let's just test
them let's take a wee so we take a ten
of these different signals and we
exhaustively sample those bases that let
me just see what the distribution is and
how much those bases affect the binding
we also look for the monomer body right
the little was previously suggested
there was monomers so I said okay let's
mutate a whole bunch of sites and take
one side away and ask what happens so
this is what because of the customized
platform we can get from Agilent we can
play these questions and the question
I'm really interested to know now is
whether this provides this new insight
whether we can make slightly better
models by just doing this excruciating
detail whether this is just useless and
I'm wasting my time so know either way
in about a month after we finally chewed
through all the data but I think it'll
be worth it so here's a in the last
couple minutes I'm just going to give
you a brief overview of what the data
looks like again we just got it last
week clearly when we scatter these so
this is the PBM data and here we haven't
used eight MERS we've a these are just
like the snip site sorts the same
sequence flank contexts you know where
directly comparable measures and we see
these so this is one experiment
replicated over ten replicants but we'll
be doing multiple experiments and
replicate
over those as well and I'm not going to
have time to talk about we're also going
to do this at multiple concentrations to
get a better feel for because obviously
these are single concentration
measurements we're going to do it a
couple different concentrations of the
protein to see whether we can
interrogate no different affinity ranges
doing and we've published previously on
the utility of this important we see
those clearly higher specific binding
demarcated by the strong off diagonal
components so there's clearly sites that
are specific to earth seven here so r 7
binds these or five doesn't and vice
versa and the question we really want to
know now is with really good models can
we understand that interferon data tells
you about before I could just make
models for those interference I feel
like I would have made progress so we're
going to take predictions from this data
set make reporter genes that have those
things change the change the site from
one of these two one of these and ask do
I see the change in a gene expression
like I expect from the simple model I'm
going to go through a little quicker I
just want to highlight a couple things
so so here's an example of snip tight
probes so here's one seed sequence and
here's all the different mutant
mutations to that and again here's high
opinion here's going into low affinity
this experiment I think we need to do a
higher concentration but here's okay I
thought it was a dude we do the same
thing with this one and again we see
that there's some clear differences the
irf five likes these gatah type
alternate sites we if you just look at
the where the red is on this axis it's
it's bound well by or five but really
poorly by our seven so for us that's a
nice prediction okay let's go look at
them the interferon zaatar five
regulates and ask is this simple enough
long and can we change something to
become our five sensitive from Earth
seven cents we also believe because this
is such a minor change that we can find
the amino acid we're making mutations to
see if we can switch or seven into an f5
and then we'll ask whether that simple
amino acid change can can explain
differential interferon expression so
we're looking to do those in the coming
month
so here's the heart of the issue I have
with the models so here's just three and
I don't mean to be unfair comparing to
the DOMA data because I think they're
wonderful data set something they put us
in a place to start this process but
here's the level of disagreement that I
need to understand if we want to make
really detailed models I need to
understand this so for example for these
three sites earth sevens on this axis it
our data says this site's really strong
and these two are lower probably ok but
about the same this is a disagreement
with the PWM which says this it's
insensitive to the see here but we see
that there's a change ok so you can say
well that's just a minor thing there's
going to be differences between models
and pw ms learned from high through data
you know and I understand that but the
question is for us for this problem we
really want very detailed models just
for these factors and so I feel like I
need to push a little farther so this is
why we're going through all the song and
dance of making very detailed
measurements and asking can we improve
the models and the same thing is
demonstrated here these are the same two
sites now we're looking on this axis we
see that the specificity is very
different we see its flipped so the PWM
predicts that the sea would be favored
here but when we measure it we see that
the G is favorite did you know this
one's slow farther on this axis ok so
the small differences maybe they don't
matter as we do reporter assays we're
going to see whether this matters for
gene expression because I don't have a
feel for this yet and I think many of us
don't and we this came up in the
discussion last night how much does an
affinity in terms of what what's
relevant in terms of gene expression and
so for these factors where we have
really biologically relevant questions
to ask in terms of cytokine expression
we're going to try to push this and
understand word of small differences
make a difference in how much of they
make a difference okay I'm just going to
go ahead so again I talked about testing
things like monomers and stuff we also
looked at the flanks and so this is just
early looks it we clearly see that these
positions have an effect okay so let me
just wrap up right here so I think that
again these rich data sets sometimes or
not I think by just if you care i think
looking deeply at the data and ask
does the simple model really explain
everything I'm looking at particularly
for foreclosed paralogs we could you
know things are the same they should
look like a line and they do when you do
replicas your clothes home logs and when
they don't there are differences and the
question is I think these differences
are important and we should drill down i
think the zinc-finger story was an
example of that that there there's a lot
hiding underneath simple motifs the
second story again we certainly see that
these factors exhibit clear differences
as suggested by some of the motif but I
think even beyond that and that we're
really trying to understand whether
customized pbms four factors we care
about can provide more insight and
better models that will allow us to get
more precise predictions for the gene
regulatory impact and they're all of
snips on these things okay in summary so
this work was done by all the irf work
was done by calendar graduated in my lab
and brian is a technician who helped
finish up the zinc-finger story and that
was done in with martha bowl across to
the postdoc okay thank you very much
so this is the assumption is the way I
see it in your coverages variable is
that that you have a lot of come along
they must have been specified also there
it means specified you somehow is
evolutionary became more specific to
some sites right but there is the other
direction that people have talked about
that there is an advantage to having
redundancy improve even though they
might be doing very similar things and
white people have looked at that is to
look at the resulting gene expression of
knockers mmm did you compare these very
nice to girls and also you said msn to
understand for almost identical but
innocent you and the other one I'm not
did you prepare the knockout results for
them in a similar way and look at the
rim any correlation the stupid allergies
on the PDF yeah yeah that's a great
question so we definitely did do some of
that and it was very hard to make models
so there was knockout expression data
under certain stress conditions that we
look at and there was clearly
differences in their gene expression
patterns there was data from air on
segalas lab and they looked at USD one
under certain so high salt patients and
we never came up with a really
compelling modeling said yes the
differences we see are explaining that
the gene expression differences and then
this is one of these issues where I was
leaving the lab and was already started
my own lab so so I don't have a good
answer to that I agree with you
wholeheartedly that I think that this is
just a one's tiny snapshot in the
evolution of a single family and I think
we've seen some of these things many
factors and in fact real luke and I were
talking about this morning we there's
many times we do these experiments are
like they look like replicates where
there's no differences even though we
know there's different functionality so
I think the point is there's going to be
a continuum of differences will see all
sorts of mechanisms and I think it's a
fruitful place to look but I think the
follow-up studies like you mentioned
will be really important to ask what are
the implications in vivo of those and so
this sort of start stops a little short
for telling that full story
I don't know much learning is kind of
position where metrics and models but I
was wondering whether now that you know
that it seems to be you need to identify
things that distinguish discriminate
yeah but it might make sense to use
different types of publicity models when
you have data like your state of you're
talking about differences rather than
consensus you probably want to learn a
model of each probe sequence because
it'd be very important to learn when
approached sequence differs from another
protein and yeah so you might want like
these rich convolution algorithms
because it might give you much more than
their sure sure no that's an excellent
point in fact so I'm glossing over
somebody doesn't just the time so that
the first story was what we call the
universal array and Harmon and many
others here have have looked at this in
detail how best to learn models to
predict that data so there's many of
those experiments done some nice review
articles in fact on multiple models
multiple camera models different ways of
learning linear models for that data and
so I'm just sort of I wasn't actually
even using a model here are just look
into the data and i think that there's
people who are better able to speak
about that and how to learn those models
than i do but i agree fully that
although some reviews seem to show that
basically linear models do pretty well
right harmony my i'm looking for
confirmation yeah anyhow there's this
effect of where the bunny seconds yes
your unbiased but yeah you could fit say
weight matrix like model to the two
experiments and it may be compared to
Delta Delta G coefficients right yeah
you can explain the differences in your
scallop us in terms of individual probes
and you know que viene features could be
shaped features as well yeah so there
could be these other aspects but but I
agree there's different approaches the
second when I showed it is actually much
more it was it much more limited only
because I this is the way I think of
these things and in other words I didn't
want to have to make a model and deke of
all stuff I said I just want to make the
measurements on those things change
single bases and say what is the impact
and so for those i'm really looking at
making the most minimal model i can and
so what we're struggling with right now
is we've been implementing some of the
stuff that Ramon raluca have talked
about support vector aggression to look
at both base the bases as well as shape
but then also just making the
measurements just from just a single
mutants or muta jet me ganized DNA and
saying what's the impact and just sake I
model it very dumb way based on
biophysics so in that case I'm actually
moving away from trying to learn from
these D convoluted nesta cameras to just
more direct measurements I don't know
what